so you think JC being an owner of a NFL
team would be a good thing we spent so
many years trying to get into the room
now he has a chance to get a seat at the
table you shouldn't be doing this with
this group because they're the owners us
against them mentality I don't think
there's a black-and-white issue because
Eric Reid still has a job he meal right
right next to show camper the woods the
difference between the best and a high
school when you play the best in college
and the best in NFL you work at it on
every level on every single team Perry
fastest guy you ever played with whoa
you hear Bo you hear Dionne is that the
game with boss yes is that the game with
bombs yes that's the guess the end of
buzzword but why acting it was a dark
period for the club's hanging out
gambling it's no man these dark
roads do you think is all fun and games
I was only act and he's acting you take
on that stuff yeah some of the greatest
athletes in the world are the dancefloor
in ballet Eddie George Renaissance I
mean are you kidding me it's insanity
[Music]
so today I have an absolute stud of a
guess he's the 1995 Heisman Trophy
winner 1996 NFL Offensive Rookie of the
Year one of only two running backs ever
to have 10,000 yards and never miss a
start the other name is the Hall of
Famer Jim Brown and on top of that he
got his MBA from Kellogg Business School
Northwestern University and he's acting
today just a interesting Renaissance man
that's none other than Eddie George
Eddie and Bonnie thanks for coming out
man truly yes yeah you know I look your
Chum like I was a kid in high school
watching you play at the Ohio State
University seen you run through people
man appreciate it I won in the military
I didn't play football
anyways yes any time I know you were
also part of a military academy sir in
high school how was that for you when I
was in it I hated it I didn't I didn't
enjoy literally I literally hated being
there I was forced there by my mother my
mother you know saw me going down the
path that was going to lead to
destructive behavior and really not have
a prosperous future so you know I'm but
my environment was not supporting the
words coming out of my mouth or the
dreams that I had in my head my heart I
was a follower more than so than a
leader and basically I was a knucklehead
and I was going nowhere at what age was
Oh 52 two guys old and long story short
she says be the 14 military academy
fights fight screaming and kicking was a
seven-hour drive
nineteen eighty orange T wing Mustang
with the you take the sunroof own and I
didn't see but I have to use the
bathroom the entire time you know that's
it
you know I was I was pissed get down
there lo and behold I start to realize
that man this might just be the place
for me because every college recruiter
in the country comes through the school
from Akron to Alabama it's a Clemson to
one EE schools Youngstown State did you
know that I really did I know God I kind
of did my research so I said this could
be the spot to me and it was didn't have
success early when I got down there but
once I began to really yield to the
discipline aspects of it and fall in
line with what the school could do for
me and use the resources for my benefit
man has just took off
it really did you know my work ethic
picked up my grades picked up the
discipline in terms of being in the
barracks being a leader in the barracks
leave are you away from family at this
time I'm in the middle of Virginia bro
I'm like it's Richmond in
Charlottesville you know between those
two cities smack dab in the middle is
Fork Union
there's no gauge there's no security
there's no dogs we leave he's a hundred
miles one way then 30 miles in a morning
how often are you seeing family I see
him on Christmas and spring spring break
that's it that was it and that's what
you elected to stay one more year
apparently yeah because I didn't have a
place to go because of my my my
performance in class doing my early high
school years and that just be a lesson
to those kids that we don't want to play
football in college I mean it starts in
the ninth grade
you know colleges look at your GPA at
that point and I was you know getting
D's and F's and proud of it and thinking
it's funny and cute thinking oh I'm
gonna my football talents going to
surpass all that it's gonna get me into
a college you know I didn't have a great
SAT score and
really embarrassing what it was and my
GPA was low and I didn't have a college
to go to I had a partial scholarship
offer from Edinboro and Pennsylvania my
senior year and no disrespect to
Edinboro I just felt like there was no I
wanted to do more in college for whom I
wanted to accomplish and be the best
among the great players in the nation
and compete on that level so I elected
to go back for postgraduate year and
that was elect you elected to go yeah
I'd like to the elected to go back
that's pretty impressive so at what
point did you know I have two goodies to
play in the NFL what age was it for and
I talked to Kobe Kobe's like at 13 years
old
I knew I wanted to be one of the
greatest ever played a bass played
basketball
what age were you like I think I can
really play at the next level was there
any Asia you experienced that uh I've
always desired to play at the next level
as a child growing up in Philadelphia I
always wanted to play in the NFL but
there was levels to it you know I was so
infatuated with the college game being
the pageantry the the traditions the
history a grew up loving Penn State I
was a big joke a fan they were
independent school at the time simply
everybody
norther Dayne Miami Michigan you know a
pit I mean it was this I grew up on
those rivalries and those matchups and I
wanted nothing more than to go to State
College and and play running back up
there that was that was my goal in my
dream but I elected the good Ohio State
because they wanted me to play running
back over line back around Penn State
Joe public that means a linebacker you
got a big job seriously I mean but did
you Lane did you play line in high
school what did you play I'm Slade
running back in high school I told my
coach am i playing linebacker because if
I play linebacker and show just a just
just the slightest type of potential I'm
never gonna see the offensive side of
the football so back then I mean listen
running backs back then we're just as
important or not more important than the
quarterback and that was a revered
position an esteemed position you played
running back on the team like Chicago
the Chicago
bears or the San Francisco 49ers or Eric
Dickerson at the Rams the Raiders I mean
Bo Jackson Marcus Allen asked those in
any euro Campbell you know with the
Houston Oilers Toni door said the name
goes on and on so I really wonder total
rock was there a guy you were looking at
coming up was there somebody that
inspired you were you I was just taking
the game just the Walter Payton was was
the standard growing up in the eighties
without a doubt I was very familiar with
Hugh McIlhenny you played the with the
galloping ghosts did all my research on
on Jim Brown the great Jim Brown washes
watch this tape OJ Simpson I was a big
fan of running backs period but the the
standard the example the man was
sweetness period sweetness was a man
this wisdom at the table yes sir Wow yes
sir because he wouldn't click pain on
you yeah you know this thing was hit
them before they hit you you guys got
similar quads though your legs and your
growth is if you look at the I mean if
you look at Payton it just doesn't make
any sense he was a gazelle man he would
explode into you I mean he was just it
was a joy to watch great athleticism
balance speed but what separated him for
most was his tenacity he ran with the
relentless spirit as a running back you
have to run from the spirit yeah it's
not you don't think your way through a
game you don't just get by you know you
will yourself to turn out those yards
you will yourself to break tackles you
will yourself to pick up a critical
fourth down or a touchdown when you have
to happen you people know you're gonna
get the ball and that's what that's what
you do you know I'm getting it I know
I'm getting it now let's see who's gonna
win Eddie what's the biggest difference
you played high school you played
college you played NFL the what's the
difference between the best and high
school when you played the best in
college and the best in NFL biggest
difference you noticed work ethic okay
your work ethic how you pay attention to
your craft on every level I've seen guys
if working in that war
freaks of nature way off the chart
athletes better than me
fast stronger quicker so again you know
it's paying attention to what's
important and the game of football and
my education was very important to me so
I had to work hard than anybody else I
refused to leave the gym without getting
every last set in I would miss meals
because I would have to finish up my
workout after work you know wouldn't eat
some nights just to get your work I had
to give so every single rep in any
somebody looks at you and they look at
your physique and they say you're a
human specimen I mean well you know you
come and you look at this body you say
the way he runs the way he runs through
people you know it's insanity how much
of it in your level of getting to the
NFL is God given a physique genetics
right how much of it is that how much of
it is discipline how much of it is
association how much of it is being a
student how much of it is mental and
emotional if you were to put them
together what would you say it really
comes down to well you got to have the
physical attribute number one I mean
you've got to have the god-given talent
what separates Hall of Famers from guys
that are good mm-hmm again is the work
that you put in you got to put in the
work and not just on the field not just
in terms of your body in terms of your
mind you got to spend time in the
classroom you've got to spend time
breaking down film doesn't understand
first of all who you are with the guys
on your defense or offense are doing or
doing and then understanding what the
other team is doing and understanding
the coordinator as well that's a plan
against the defensive coordinator and
what his tendencies are who's the
offensive coordinator the opponent's
that's important yeah the opponent if
it's corny you're studying the defensive
coordinator you know his personality you
know he likes to do you know he likes to
get aggressive when you go into the red
zone you know you can play a bin but
don't break mentality and
you know you get all of a sudden you
cross that 20-yard line all hell breaks
loose because you're getting the Blitz
from every angle or you might get a guy
like you know Rex Ryan's gonna blitz no
matter where you're on the field or
great waves so it's understanding all of
that you know and also taking care of
your body and and doing what others
aren't willing to do you know I took
ballet lessons when I was in high school
I remember I read an article about they
took ballet lessons yeah and it was all
you know to make me a better all-around
athlete some of the greatest athletes in
the world are on the dance floor and in
ballet by the way Arnold took ballet
Arnold the bodybuilder mr. Olympia
dabeli
Herschel Walker took ballet Herschel
yeah so some of the greatest athletes of
our time have taken a ballet
what did that do for you was it
flexibility flexibility was balanced it
was training muscles that typically
don't have a chance to get strengthened
through traditional strength training
methods when you're playing football or
basketball to take this body 245-pound
body and move it gracefully across the
floor doing demi-plié aims and spins and
having to land gracefully forcing myself
to do that time and time again what I've
on the football field and I have to do a
spin it's gonna be second nature
so it was cross-training for me it's
taking everything that allow apply
immersing myself to really understanding
the craft of being what we call it I
don't know what I would call ballerina
for me I don't know what it would be for
that I I really had to lose myself in
that and become that so when I went back
on the football field I would be an
enhanced person of myself a different
version of myself is you think you think
a part of that is what helped you last
as long as you did because you know when
you look at the stats thing you got are
you is it is it the one the stat was
what you're the only running back ever
to have seven consecutive seasons or 300
the rushing attempts there's a per
season you're the only running eight
seasons to do that I mean
you think a lot of that was due to your
training and your ability to lessen see
how it was that it was the blessing of
God you know I didn't sustain any major
injuries I played hurt now I played with
a lot of different anchors but I think
it was because of my training and
everything else everybody's well worn
out and this and that nah no I could
have played you know four or five more
years I think you returned out 31 I mean
you're 31 yeah and I would have my role
would have been different
certainly I would have been a backup
somewhere but I didn't want that life
for me at that particular time and I you
know if I was gonna do that role I would
like to have done it in Nashville or
with the Tennessee Titans who was who
was in your draft I know first pick was
Keyshawn well who else who else was in
yours right because your draft is a
stack to drink over 96 yeah he was 14 to
14th Marvin Harrison the Hall of Fame
Terrell Terrell Owens Hall of Fame yeah
we're a Lewis Hall of Famer Jonathan
Ogden Hall of Famer Simeon rice
who's up for the hall Kevin Hardy
Keyshawn was one Tim beocca Pachuca
Terry Glenn Rickey Dudley were all in
there that's a stacked Alexander else am
I missing
I mean that's just to name a few yes
just it was a loaded loaded rat Zach
Thomas Zach Thomas Miami's army yeah
yeah absolutely tall was act by the way
was he four five eight five nine he
wasn't a tall guy right Zach no no it
was about five
Zach was about five nine but we'll knock
your head off so when you he hit you
they move oh you know you'll feel the
hardest-hitting guy you got hit by a lot
of guys who was the hardest listen
everybody asked me that question
no one sticks out over the other I mean
there's certain guys you got to look out
for no question John Lynch certainly Ray
Lewis John Lynch
47 yes Derek Thomas on that level you're
gonna have a headhunter or two or three
on every single team period so it's not
like well
you know this guy's hard as you can do
to avoid and is there and make some
money saying yeah there are yeah you can
you can over pursue and make a Miss or
you can you can set them up as if you
want to you know make them moving and
run into him or you can just meet him in
the hole what you did a lot of that was
that was your specialty you could do
that yeah was there running back who was
the one running back I remember he was
six five - forty - fifty warrants
something was at a Chris Warren he
played for Seattle yeah Chris Warren
Chris warning Chris Warren he was a big
guy - was about 6 - yeah Chris was 16
last a long time but I think he's gotten
some some recognition for I think
four-time Pro Bowler I think I was one
no no I give him credit remaining out of
Virginia right he was Virginia yes he
was he was a guy that came and I'm like
this guy's pretty exciting to watch you
know at a time where you're like you
know there's not a lot of exciting
things to watch with the team it was
apart fast this guy you ever played with
whoa you hear Bo you hear Dionne who's
the fastest guy you ever saw where
you're like I cannot even believe how
fast this goes Joey Galloway you know
these cagey was to me I mean that hands
down JG and we had some fast guys on our
team Shawn Springs Terry was fast our
corners were exceptionally fast yeah
guys never heard of that could run but
Joey and a ten yard sprint would beat
everybody by five yards everybody by
five dogs he will beat me by seven for
one sanity yeah that's insane it was
nothing right now it almost 50 years old
he's won on the for 350 or so money
before I think he's gonna be 48 this
year so yeah you believe the myth that
Bo cracked for one like you you do
believe the myth listen there's no myth
you look at the man's highlights if
someone told you that this guy could
break a bat over his head he can he can
gun somebody from left field and hit him
out get him out a third run up a wall
catch a fly five flies with one hand
a sharpshooter in terms of rifles in
archery archery you'd be like god that's
that's no oh yeah legit have
you been a chance have you ever had a
chance to chop it up oh my gosh I go to
bull Jackson's have been every year bo
and I have really formed a great
relationship over the past five years
fact five years yes he's older than me
play before my time
of course growing up it was Bono's
played with a play Tecmo Bowl
yes used bo and destroyed made a lot of
money destroyed their opponents and I've
had a chance to go to his golf
tournament over the last four or five
years and he's come and done some stuff
for me in Columbus Ohio and we just
really have developed a wonderful
relationship just hearing the stories
and listening to his philosophy it's how
he grew up you know what's the most
unique story you've ever heard about Bo
or personal experience or a story you
heard where it's like insane yeah there
was a play called in Oakland I don't
know if this is the correct name for it
but it was called Bo don't need no
blocking it's a play called Bo don't
need no blocking something along those
lines but he don't need no blocking so
they will call it they were overload the
field right you pitch the ball he'll
take two steps to the right and counter
back left and score and whoever was on
the edge corner defensive back whomever
had to deal with that that's what he
said
not only blocking think about that
that's insane and the jump off a
baseball diamond did jump on the field
on Monday Night Football and to
annihilate the Seattle Seahawks on
national television one that 90-yard
touchdown fresh off of the baseball
diamond to be in football shape to do
that is that the game with Bosworth yes
is that began with boss yes that's the
guess the end of Bosworth and
Metsu we start and we start to the
downfall yeah that but I tell you what
Bojack man is between him and Dion
probably that's a tough ones prime prime
so Joe you know you know in the NBA you
do you played it the game of draft and
you pick a player and I pick a player
and you hey you got first pick I'll pick
MJ I got a second I'll take LeBron and
Shaq or whoever if you're putting the
team together you got a draft tool it's
your first draft pick actually who do
you pick all time pick somebody who are
you building around as number one
all-time running back or just players
you you got a pick you got a pick what
do you pick
man that's a tough one um I gotta go
with a quarterback you got to go with
quarterback so you're putting that as
number one position today gotta go with
a quarterback now you got a handful of
choices there yeah you do
I'm leaning to her Peyton Manning
because he is so consistent and I played
against Peyton and there's a lot of guys
to pick from this Tom Brady and you take
Peyton first over Manning over a Brady
because I don't haven't seen Tom out of
New England I've seen Peyton when a
Super Bowl in Denver you see what I'm
saying he wanted what a defense though
when you want people joked about it
himself or with this you've won over the
defense in Indianapolis but Peyton is so
lethal man I mean he's such a chess
player on the field and he he's so smart
he can manipulate a defense and I would
I would I would start with a meanness
it's a tough choice Tom Brady is the
ultimate competitor I mean a man has six
rings for crying out loud you know but I
mean this is just splitting hairs but I
mean in terms of arm Talent Manning
build around me build around Manning
yeah and by the way the you you won
Heisman wasn't he sixth that year I
think it was six cuz it was a second
year it was six dad you when you wanted
yeah and you know here's a guy that went
from like he's a scientist when it comes
to when you look at him from the outside
you thinking he's got a personality he's
a math guy prepared the neck issue come
back interesting so you would call them
the greatest of all time okay that you
said okay fair enough all time that's a
different that's a different that's a
completely different you're going
sweetness you're going you're going
you can go Jim Brown you're gonna go Jim
Brown I mean Jim he could play in any
era and just would he I mean he put up
the amount of yards he put up was 16
over 16,000 and I think eight or nine
years and they only played with 12 games
I believe see that's one of the reasons
why he gets to kind of respect he does
from the players and partly what he did
for the community and how he was as an
actor both yeah I mean he was a better
lacrosse player he was a football player
so what does that tell you Wow yeah
urban legend that's better lacrosse
player a better lacrosse player than he
was he football that is insane so anyone
you getting the call when are they gonna
call you when they're gonna call when
God moves at the happen man how
important is that for you for that to
become a reality I'd be lying to say if
it wasn't important
I'd be greatly honored
I'm obviously obviously mm-hmm you got a
lot of guys rooting for you by the way a
lot of guys would well I appreciate it
um but you know I'm one to believe if
I'm if I'm worthy of being in the Hall
of Fame I'll be in it if not I can still
get my sleep at night you know I put
everything I had into the game squeezed
everything out of it that I could have
possibly imagined the the platform has
opened up so many opportunities for me
in business
me personally spiritually had the
opportunity to meet people from all
crosses of walks in the entire world so
to be recognized as a hall-of-famer
would be wonderful but again it's that
it's not up to me they have to go
through their process and if I'm worthy
I'm worthy you're comfortable with that
I'm comfortable that's great that's
because I know I was watching
I think it was moss and Ray Lewis they
were talking and they were talking about
how you belong and then they mentioned
you and I think it's Fred Taylor we're
talking about the two names that they
got a bond and when you look at
statistically your average per season
yards is what the seventh highest and
there's five NFL running backs in who
are lower than you so even if it's an
argument and a case being made the
numbers back it up you know yeah yeah
III guess you look at the numbers you
look at a lot of different factors what
else do they look at whatever you know
bow down to the NFL for them to say yes
or hey you know what man I don't know
what it is I wish I knew what the
criteria was or is I know that they're
trying to get a lot of guys in you're up
against a lot of different it's not just
my position but Europe against guys from
the past you know against guys that are
coming out this year and eligible and
it's only like four or five slots for
players so again you know if and when is
my time it'll be my time well we're
looking forward to that time and it
comes because again a lot of people
believe you belong in there but let me
transition to another part you know what
one of the things that you're looking at
right now with the NFL going on with
jay-z and the whole conversation with
Kaepernick and yeah why are you going
from the NBA and now you're sitting
there talking right next to Roger
Goodell and there's all this controversy
what are you feeling about the whole
thing taking place today well I look at
it from both sides from the players side
from the community side and certainly
from jay-z side jay-z is obviously one
of the greatest if not the greatest MCS
of all time he's transformed himself
well he's probably always been a great
businessman but he's made some great
business moves given the situation in
the NFL with Colin Kaepernick he brought
light to a situation that really needed
to be focused on and I think he did just
that he served his purpose in doing that
he being Kaepernick's Serbia's campus
terms of bringing it to social justice
short shoes short and and having a
platform to speak from and so forth now
the question becomes is how do we
collectively move forward where is the
win-win for the NFL and where's the
win-win for social justice and players
allowing themselves to express
themselves and that in that regard and
have freedom of speech and so forth
so I think there at that point now where
they want to move forward to say okay
we're beyond you know bringing a light
to an issue that we already know what
the issue is what are now the solutions
to have guys make a difference a real
difference in our communities when it
comes to social and justices and so
forth and the NFL being in harmony with
that so there is no dissension so
somebody can't just hijack that platform
and use it for political reasons which
it was used for to begin with so that's
where we were down this road and I hate
the fact that you know in our
communities you know you got some guys
that are coming at J and J has to defend
themselves you know and that's not
really where the war is we're all trying
to move the needle forward in terms of
bringing light to social injustice not
who's right who's wrong you shouldn't be
doing this with this group because
they're the owners us against them
mentality well the owners they give you
your paycheck so they why not try to
figure out a way to move forward and B
reunite and try to come up with
solutions versus same as us versus them
and I think that's and this is what he
was trying to come across it's and he's
a listen man he's a piece of influencer
and people listened to Jay so there are
not many bigger influencers than him in
the community so so that's what I'm
saying
and if if it takes for him to say okay
do you want me to be involved in your
halftime show sure all right this is
what I want to do for the community I
want to move the needle for
I think we've got got lost was well what
about Colin Kapernick and a job now you
know do I think that he's been
blackballed to some degree or white ball
topper you want to say yes you know he
did take a settlement if I if my memory
serves me correctly I think four
different teams reached out to him at
that particular time and I think it may
come down to whether he's gonna be a
starter or backup or whatever he may not
have done this I don't know the
particulars of that I can't believe
speak intelligently on that but the
opportunities were there so the bottom
line is can he still play football the
game of football can he can he be a
integral part of a team to help them win
and produce wins and touchdowns and all
of that that's the question that has to
be asked in terms of somebody bringing
them in because bringing the veteran
that's gonna be money in this game is
it's a young man's game and every sense
of the word younger means cheaper labor
hmm
got it all right so that's that's
dollars and cents so I don't think
there's a black-and-white issue because
Eric Reid still has a job and he Neil
right right next to show company he's
with the Carolina Panthers on point it's
a good point so you know that's kind of
that's kind of Hollis yeah now from your
perspective for you you've been to you
you served in our military how do you
see the situation I think from the
standpoint of what Colin was trying to
do NFL has always been a big Pro
military yeah organization they just
have been it's almost like a sponsorship
this is what we represent you know this
is what we support
mhm MBAs been slightly different they
all have a little bit of it but it's
been different so when you do that and
the biggest you know message you're
giving us to veterans we stand for them
the veteran community is a little bit
upset by they're offended by it and
their interpretation now Colin may come
back and explain and say hey I don't
think this is the case this is not what
I was doing I was not trying to
disrespect that which is fine yet then
he goes to Miami tryouts and he's
wearing a Castro then it's a shot at the
Cuban community and you know you're in
Miami so some and then you were some
stuff with pigs and you know there there
is limits to it and so if you're if
you're poking at it like let's just I
run a company
and people come to me and they say hey
we don't think this company is a equal
opportunity for women editors as it is
for men okay what's the first thing you
gonna do maybe you're gonna take a look
at it let me see if we got the
opportunity and then from there you make
adjustments but if it's constant and
adjustments are being made I don't know
so I don't I don't just think he's going
only after the fact that he doesn't feel
his community has it he took shots at
you know at the Cuban community took
shots a lot of people and you go back to
saying talking about Reed Reed still got
a job today yeah and that was what
Stephen I submit said I'm Kirsten on
what you say about this Stephen
Highsmith said there is this notion that
the moment a jay-z has to make a
decision like this with a Roger Goodell
you're selling out to the white man to
move up you know there's some of that
taking place
I'm Middle East or now from Iran I
wasn't born yet was an immigrant when I
10 years old went to Germany I lived at
a refugee camp and I came here there's a
little bit of that in the Middle Eastern
community say hey you sold out to the
white man to move up in the business
world let's just say they say that to me
so partly I'm looking at J and I'm
saying listen this is a guy that's his
entire career is into everything he's
done it to about giving back why are you
it's your prize he's being all of us we
spent so many years trying to get into
the room where the decisions happen we
finally get into the room now he has a
chance to be a get a seat at the table
you know there isn't a lot of diversity
with among among the owners of the NFL
mm-hmm not a lot I don't think there any
there aren't any african-american owners
in the NFL so in some respects you
almost have to applaud him for even a
tip even if I think his rumors that
floated out around the NFL around this
about him being an owner and so forth I
don't know but if that were the case you
want somebody that looks like you that
can represent you so when cases like
this come up there's a point of
reference you have somebody that can can
represent that to some degree so to say
that he's selling out I don't know at
some point about how do you move the
needle along if you don't
have the other person involved it's
always going to be dissension I'm more
about okay we've had an issue that
solved the issue now how does everybody
win how do we move forward so everybody
feels like they're gonna win you know so
that's that's where I'm the notional
these do you see something on how this
is this needs to happen for everybody to
feel like there's a compromise there's a
collaboration word work for everybody
everybody everybody in the party you're
not gonna satisfy everybody you're not
going you're not going to that's what
I'm saying it's just not going to happen
yeah well I think in in terms of
understanding that the NFL is not going
anywhere it's not they're not gonna shut
it fell down
it's next man up and you saw the Cowboys
the valuation just showed up five five
so it's going down in the world I don't
know where so what are you gonna do
continue to fight that or say okay we
want our voices to be heard one our
issues to be heard how do we do it
that's in concert with everybody else
here we've listened what light to the
issue and one respect now how do we move
forward from that or do we continue to
still fight and continue to you know
boycott the NFL not watch games that
didn't have that zero effect on you know
from some friends that said they don't
watch the NFL because of this event
teach his own but it has zero effect on
their bottom line in fact it increased
streaming in and now we're gambling and
there's different revenue streams that
are being created it's it's the number
one the number one American sport right
you know so III don't know I mean again
I feel like there's a wonderful
wonderful opportunity to really find a
platform and create a platform where
everybody wins
and that's why Stan yeah it's gonna be
so you think jay-z being an owner of a
football team NFL team would be a good
thing I don't see why I wouldn't okay I
don't really don't do you see that
happening anytime soon I mean I don't
listen I know he's a billionaire but
these guys that have these teams these
teams are their hobbies
the core businesses energy is private
equity hello that about magic you know
magic doesn't own 50% of the Dodgers no
he's he's kind of there would you know
partners yes I see I see jay-z being
able to do something like that it would
be interesting you know he's already
doing some stuff on the other side I did
he was at the Brooklyn Nets now you know
he's really gotten befriended a craft I
only could see it from a distance I'm
not I don't know intimately in terms of
doing things together so it's about
coming together and and pushing it
forward it'll be interesting to see
where this goes one of the things I like
about Steven a is he will make the case
for both sides even if he disagrees with
this human there's a voice like him out
there to keep pushing everybody I think
he's good for all in the same but we're
all trying to get promising yeah the
finish line but we're doing a different
way exactly there's no right or wrong
way right exactly as long as people are
seeing the progress taking place it's
good you know one of the things I'm
curious to ask you is Kenny Smith I
don't know if you Kenny Smith MBA time
the Miami Heat is playing against
Indiana Pacers okay
the the Pacers are up a point and you
know coach Vogel takes out the center at
the time Hibbert if you remember Hibbert
tall 72 73 74 yeah he takes him out and
everybody said wait a minute what are
you doing here taking him out he's been
playing the defense against LeBron he
takes him out they passed the ball to
LeBron free throw he turns around goes
makes a layup with his left hand they
win the game the game ends okay Kenny
Smith says the following I got I think
you kind of know where I'm going with
this Kenny Smith asks a question he has
this question he says everybody's like
well you know I hope they come back next
year and I feel good about Indiana
because the direction they're going with
Paul George and these guys are kind of
coming together etc etc and Kenny said I
don't know if I agree I don't know if I
agree he says what do you mean he says
look when Jordan retired there was a
two-year win
to win a title and we pulled it off and
Chuck didn't obviously that those young
years yeah Houston took it and he was
part of the team and Chuck wasn't he
says I don't know if there'd be a place
like that right now when you get your
chance you got to do it so let me go
back you know what I'm going with this
your Super Bowl okay you guys make the
comeback McNair is doing his part good
second half you're there I think you're
on the 10-yard line 9 yard line I don't
know exactly where it was you're on the
10 yard line and you played a hell of a
hell of a game I think you got 28
carries if I'm correct 95 yards you got
two touchdowns you got 35 yards
receiving zero fumbles you're having a
good game okay
on the other side Warner's thrown
another 400 yard game in a you know
super bowl he's the only guy that's
thrown three four hundred yard games and
Super Bowls on the Saints yes so then
that play takes place they call it The
Longest Yard right okay
similar thing happened with what'd he
call it with Marshawn Lynch with Seattle
was going up against New England I
believe but they were two yard line you
were on the 10 yard line
looking back do you ever everybody
experiences loss some of us as business
some of us is married some of us has
held some of us as a mistake cost the
life of somebody a mistake somebody got
into drew everybody has something that
they look and none of us are free of it
it happens to be yours was a little bit
more public than everybody else and the
ball wasn't even in your hands and Dyson
still got nine yards on it do you ever
look at that insane what if we ran a
different play
do you ever process it that way for
yourself no you don't no no got it now
let me ask you when you look at when
Seattle went against New England do you
ever look at her say that was two yards
why don't you give the ball to Marshawn
Lynch and they had a timeout yeah and it
couldn't stop and it wasn't seven points
you guys were seven points that you were
behind I think yours was 23 - we would
we would have tied the game and an
opportunity to tie the game with a extra
point mm-hmm me I don't look at it for
terms of us know I don't think I think
he had the right call you had the right
category Kevin was supposed to take one
more yard
wanted to sell it a little bit more but
Mike Jones made it one hell of a play
and came underneath it and made the
tackle and everybody still remembers
Super Bowl 34 but in terms of Marshawn
Lynch I was little perplexed by that
call given that okay on the field it
says yes we should have thrown the
football because they had the numbers in
the box and single covers every we had
exactly what they were looking at and
Malcom Butler made a hell of a play but
in terms of we'll go back to the
position of the running back and used to
go to timeout and you got beast mode
back there I'm gonna put my money on
beast mode at the one-yard line with all
the chips on the line to give me my
winning touchdown to solidify my second
Super Bowl win that's when I put my
money on you know I believe his will to
win will get me that when versus saying
okay the numbers suggest that we should
go to the passing game based off of what
we see out of this defensive look so
that's what I would have done but you
know that's why I'm at home coaching how
do you how does how does it for like
game is over you go to the locker room
Jeff what is he telling you guys in that
moment would you say yes much is it like
a short conversation and you just kind
of go move on and you let everybody go
home what is that conversation like it's
really no conversation it's more of just
being there to console one another and
to embrace one another and to say man
I'm proud of you
and to kind of decompress I mean it's
not much you can say we all knew what it
was we all knew we fought hard we all
knew we came in within one yard of
holding up or possibly holding up a
Lombardy trophy
but it wasn't anything that we could do
anything about it's not like the one for
the Gipper next year mm-hmm I think once
the dust settled for me I was ready to
go back
I was inspired you were inspired you had
a hell of a season that yes 16
touchdowns for 1500 yards I think you
got eight votes for MVP at your Marshall
Marshall kidding me oh that was a
thousand so you came back after there
came back out of it yeah so it wasn't
the best season you had the Super Bowl
that was the following year so you came
back the top which was one - it was
reckoned Lee
13:13 and three other lost against
Baltimore that was a different story but
it's part of the game you know and the
reason why I asked this question is
because in the business world Eddie if I
tell you a couple of the deals I've done
where you're like oh my gosh how did
this go how did I want to see this I
what if we could have done this I think
sometimes you know when it happens to
some people they think it's the very
only person that goes through it this is
man you don't get your ass kicked on the
football field you'll get your ass
kicked in the field of business and I
know what it is to command the football
field and in business if we speak the
same land to a Kellog how was that for
you I was a hard man it was it was tough
but I relished in the fact that I wanted
to be comfortable and being
uncomfortable because that's the reason
why I went was to learn about finance to
learn about different business practices
to learn how I could take my business to
the next level you know from being a
hundred thousand a couple of dollars to
a million a million to billions you know
to realize that hell you know what maybe
this core business is not really what I
need to do
maybe to do a pivot and do something
else something that really supports my
network my knowledge the things I have
access to and really build an enterprise
and that was that was a very tough
situation because it was um some things
I didn't just didn't know I had to take
accounting classes I'd take finance
classes before I even went to Kellogg I
had to go to Belmont University before
you went well with the Kellogg to prove
that I could handle the low and here's a
oh my god were you kind of you were
earlier embarrassed to tell your SAT
score yes and you're going to kill off
going to Kellogg maybe exactly so it was
a purely an effort thing back in the
days versus then you a small effort man
you're not amazing yeah I tell my son
like that all the time school comes easy
to most yeah but I was a grinder and I
didn't want to grind back then on the
education side but I realized that for
me to have more opportunities and really
for me to grow and become the
businessman that I wanted to reach my
full potential and this is what I needed
to go through some people are different
hope is he didn't have his MBA was in
the streets his MBA was in and and and
wrap in the rap game and records and all
of that and that's how he became the
billionaire that he is my road is a
little different I got to go to school
learn with the constant case studies at
Kellogg study after case love the case
that not the best deal of yeah you get
when you have a chance to get a case
study yeah I'm a nerd like that you get
the paper you kind of go through it so
you enjoy your enjoy the case study yeah
you get the case study that you take out
the numbers if it's a finance case study
extract the numbers you look at he says
they've done differently here were they
losing money up you look at the contrast
you getting the new the minutiae of it
and that's that's what the learning
happens and then you have some guy
that's from India who's in the banking
industry or an invent or in banking or
finance or engineer engineer whatever
and they talk about that same issue that
they had how they solved it you know or
didn't solve it and it's like wow this
is really good stuff and then the real
part of the education is afterwards when
you go out into the hallways and you eat
together and you're talking you build
relationships and you create synergy and
talking about ideas and you're putting
projects together so that that to me was
a priceless experience that I paid for
out of my pocket that's that's been how
old were you when you went to that I was
[Music]
34 34 35
this is Padukone acting school and
you're going to kill oh yeah I was doing
the Simon listen man
you're non-famous both I was listen my
sketch impressive Eddie I mean I I
thought I thought Kellogg was post post
like recent you know now graduated in
2009 yeah yeah so so we left NFL and
you're doing acting for you said ten
years you you you you notice you're
acting during the week yeah commentating
on the weekends flying from LA going
from Nashville to LA LA to Chicago back
to Nashville my wife was on the show
survivor so she's gone my son is 3 years
old at that particular time I youngest
so it's a lot my family's I was all over
the place man trying to figure it out
and have a career and commentating maybe
I spread myself too thin as well I'm I
don't see me anymore
with that but you know it was was a
wonderful experience to do it because
now I'm expanding by consolidating you
know expanding by consolidating yes
absolutely so but why acting what you're
like what's it a chicken when you were
you know you're looking at how laughter
what was commentating and I wanted to be
part of the reason I was I wanted to be
a commentator a better commentator I
felt like acting was a way for me to to
do that but acting is not therapy it's
therapeutic it's cathartic so at that
particular time when I left the game of
football there was a lot of emotions
tell me what you mean brother
there were it was a dark period for me
in terms of who I was what I was gonna
do next and how I was gonna get there
really figuring out what the hell I was
gonna do next is it is this a part of
what kind of like you know a buddy of
mine gets out of the military and he
says dude I have no idea what the hell
to do analyst I'm going from military to
civilian I'm lost he was going through a
depression he was going through anxiety
he didn't know how to make the
adjustment he's like I have no idea what
the hell to do and was it he was in his
thirties as well is it similar to it's
not world it's exactly that to go from
preparing the play in front of thousands
and thousands of people 60,000 forty
thousand hundred thousand fans every
week and chanting your name
against you to now silence in your house
with your wife your kids seeing her
every day she's used to you being gone
that's a whole new dynamic when the
relationship now so how do you who are
you and what's going to bring you peace
so I want to go back to the things that
brought me peace clubs you know hanging
out late that those thing playing cards
gambling traveling that was all the that
was all a part of who I was so long
story short I had to really seek out I
had to I went to counseling for that to
help me say okay I need some help here
what's going on how do I address this
there's no book written on it there's no
resources really about it at that
particular time 2005 now the NFL has
like people you can call on and
counseling sessions that you can go to
which is phenomenal and I recommend that
for anybody coming out of professional
sports to say okay this is what I have
this is what I've done what do I do with
this next I have money I have some
notoriety but where's my passionate now
where's my next playing field isn't in
business in the commentating is it and
and my philanthropic efforts where is it
so I had to go through all that and I
continued to go through that I continued
to go to counseling
I continued to seek their how long was
that how long it's never ending it's not
okay sections I'm good
you know I check in every so often you
know still on point with that but back
to your original question was why acting
that's why acting because I was able to
take a lot of those feelings that I
talked about and got it and filter that
through the voice of a character filter
that out through my writing and the
process of acting is telling the truth
and imaginary circumstances if stripping
away all the all the
personalities of the football player the
celebrity the the athlete
the superstar the dad and get to the
core of who I am and be able to say okay
here's a part let me tell the truth
through this part and bring healing and
light in that regard so I'm taking what
I had and using it for good so it
doesn't destroy me who are your teachers
by the way when you were gone it was a
annamaria friends Ella who god bless her
soul was no longer with us she died
about two years ago Jeff Obafemi car
currently working with God named Robert
Kiefer and Stella Reed in Nashville
Tennessee as my acting coaches Voice
coaches I'm doing it all of it because
you know again the whole idea in the
hope that the exercises of acting is
just telling stories is telling your
story and being a great communicator and
that so it doesn't matter what form it
is it can be a podcast I can be on the
boards of a stage I can be in front of a
camera I can you know be on desk at ESPN
commentating mmm it supports all of that
it's it's the training of it so so you
can get to the core of your truth
and-and-and-and and tell that in the
honest way not filter it or act it out
or premeditate certain situations be
really honest in the moment and be in
the moment
was there any advice that you got you
know your acting is reacting all this
stuff that you hear about you know and
you you know there is try to say I love
you in 50 different ways I love you I
love you I love you you know all these
that is there anything that's stuck with
you in acting was like these three
advice that I got was the best thing I
heard from somebody anything that stays
with you three words tell the truth if
you can find the truth in the material
of the character and be honest with the
truth of that within yourself and let's
tell the truth inflection voice
inflection pitch pace the powerful
Paul's voice all of that that supports
the truth
if you're getting the technique then
your technician but if you're a truth
teller and you work on the components of
the voice the pitch all of that to help
you tell the truth then it'll be
expressed that way but always get to the
core of telling the truth and be honest
and open about it be vulnerable like the
characters that scared me the most are
the ones that have to be vulnerable I
mean really emotionally vulnerable I
played some some different characters
that I had to go there and I had to be
honest with it you know like well on
this on this line I'm gonna cry here
he's gonna say it now I don't work that
way it don't work that not that I could
be doing delivering a monologue and it
was one night I just did top dog
underdog this past year and it was this
one scene where I'm talking about why
they leave us there's two brothers both
parents left them and they are fending
for themselves as teenagers you know
they had the dysfunctional relationship
and they live in this apartment together
and he comes in my character comes in
drunk just lost his job
and the brother set up this this just
the table and he's having his girlfriend
come over and he's really decked out the
apartment and so forth he has the family
album out and I'm going around the room
looking at the different stuff there's
the blind and the glasses I pick up the
family album scoped it through it
talking about the good old days and I
finally get to a point where why they
leave us and then as I'm saying this
monologue talking about the food on the
table and this and that I started having
images of my own life my father not
being there in my life and I got so
emotional in that that it shook me up to
the point where I forgot my lines
I forgot well it's because that's the
beauty of theatre and to the audience it
resonated as I guess a real moment for
me was like oh I don't know my
lines but I'm really honest here my Wow
so that's in it
was a healing moment for me because that
was suppressed probably in me and I
really didn't realize it so that's why I
love acting do you think acting is
somewhat therapeutic its therapeutic but
it's not therapy there's a difference I
think it allows you to rid yourself of
potentially things that can be toxic to
you in terms of your thinking emotions
experiences traumatic experiences that
are packed down and that can affect you
at any point in time it can come up in
your physical life you can come up in
your emotional life it can affect your
spiritual life it can really affect your
the way you think the way you hope your
faith and all of that so you know I seek
to be clear on a lot of levels and again
it's not about going to one or two
lessons or five lessons in 12 steps it's
a lifelong journey mmm I mean that's
interesting yeah very cool I'm a movie
guy and I love watching you know guys
acting how to get into their part like
oh my gosh that was sick yeah for you is
there anybody that's an aspiration you
know somebody you look up and said this
guy's acting is incredible oh there's
several of Viola Davis Denzel Denzel
he's just a beast my Viola Davis brings
just this powerful quiet
character where she is acting without
talking in her body language in her face
did what she does with her hands it's
just so brilliant and moving and such a
joy to watch
watching unfold live Samuel Jackson you
know I'm looking at a master class on
him you know when I'm not acting on the
stage I'm studying what did you take
away from it I mean I didn't take the
class what did you take away well well
the process you know talks about
character he talks about backstory the
importance of doing your homework
you know knowing who the character is
where he's coming from what he wants how
he's gonna get him was gonna do when he
gets it you know he talks about the
physicality of different characters you
have a broken leg or you have a
deficiency how do you feel about that
deficiency or how else if you're
handicapped how else are you strong were
you stronger mentally you know rich the
third to me an opportunity to do a
reading of that that's so down that's
one that I want to play because she's
twisted in his mind you know he can't do
anything physically but in terms of
being a mastermind but Richard is just a
wonderful character I would love to
explore because on the surface it
appears that he's evil but underneath
all that evil there is purpose there's a
reason why thinks he thinks and he's
justified why he's doing what he's doing
and there's a human being that you can
fall in love with this so that's the
challenge that I see Richard but all of
that he just talks about the importance
of going to your backstory and riding
out that backstory even if one is not
provided for yeah I mean this guy right
here Heath Ledger met him he's one of
the greats man oh my god
do you remember what Jack Nicholson told
him would that he said the advice he
gave never played Joker because that
part completely messes with with your
mind the deeper you get into it did you
ever hear about the story about yeah
it's no it's no man these dark
roads you know you get really listen man
you think is all fun and games I was
only acting he's acting no I mean the
real dudes like hey lesser and you take
on that stuff
yeah and you know you the power is in
the tongue what you speak will come to
life whether it's good or bad that's the
part about taking someone exactly so you
have to have a process like okay if I'm
doing this I need to be protected
spiritually mostly physically it needs
to be a process okay once I come out of
this role what is going to be now my
process to get
out of this role in a healthy way not
threw them out allowed it to come out of
that right to come out of the
consciousness process isn't it you know
acting where some stay like Daniel
day-lewis he doesn't come out Jared
literally you know he stays yeah and
they stain and there's some go in and
come out so it's no to me is no written
book on it it's it's your process and
what's healthy for you
there are times and I got and I've done
plays where I'm dreaming about the words
I'm so immersed in it and if it's dark
you know it can affect you in that way
so you you got to have something to come
back to ground you whether it's a
crystal or incense or your pictures of
your family they say this is me I'm
Eddie and I were to the Third's is that
you know so it's it's school do they
teacher like some of the role not come
back my acting coach but we strongly
suggest that have something to keep you
grounded so I'll tell you I tell you a
funny story or maybe it's not a funny
story Aaron Spicer I don't know if you
know Aaron speiser he's the acting coach
to Will Smith JLo and a lot of these
guys I'm living in LA 20-some years
right my wife gets me a gift to meet
with Aaron speiser so I got you a
session you're gonna go meet with Aaron
that's a nice gift right so I go and she
says I'm gonna go with you so I go and I
said look I've always been curious about
acting I'm Kirsten um what he's gonna
say and he asked me this question he
says you sure you want to possibly
pursue acting I'm just curious I want to
learn more about it I've always you know
as a kid I would do videos and we would
act and do all this stuff he said how
well do you do with down time I said
what do you what do you mean by that he
says he looks at my he says how how well
does he do with down time he says not
good he's terrible with down time he
says it may not be for you I said tell
me Maurice is because in that world
there's a lot of down time it's
different if you paying to fund the
movies but the down time part of it to
keep your sanity together you lose it so
if you can't control down time you may
not want to pursue you may not want to
pursue this career as an actor how do
you handle downtown for yourself now
that
you don't have you know when you're NFL
you were eight nine months out of the
year your training you all this stuff
how you handling down time downtown for
me is kind of full time because there's
the entrepreneurial side of it you know
there's the entertainment
entrepreneurship and education those are
the three buckets that I operate up my
three e's entrepreneurship education
education entertainment ER team kata so
we cover the entertainment part so when
I'm out on stage I'm developing bit my
business which is my wealth management
business where I got my serious 766 you
got your series 7 oh yeah seriously I've
been in the business for three years get
out of here yeah who are you with
the first one asks for equity core
that's not broker-dealer I'm doing
business as the Edward George Wealth
Management Group very familiar with them
I start off with Morgan Stanley Dean
would own snipe with Jones Edward George
- George George Wealth Management I like
that okay so so you're 766 to health
life yep
fully licensed and been doing it for
going on three and a half years now who
do you target is it there's a lot of NFS
or is it everybody no I'm wide open I'm
doing corporations high net worth
individual islets are you doing eyelids
you know individual living trusts you
say okay yeah it's nothing short season
saw the worth but but mainly just doing
the equity side of it how'd you get into
that what and what made you want to go
after
does anybody know is this a pretty
public life or no things you have a
website and everything but are you
promoting you that you're doing welcome
an or now uh-huh yeah so I mean I've
been doing it simultaneously with my
acting when I'm not on the stage I was
studying for my serious seven
how are you prospecting for clients
what's your approach
well most you somebody with your level
you know your Eddie George NFL football
my approach is to the education piece my
approach have been teaching Ohio State
the business of professional sports over
the last five years and it's talking
about my experiences
using my network of people from agents
financial advisors that make up the
business and we talk about the makeup of
the business of kids or understand what
life is like as an NFL player or NBA
player that what you see on television
is 100 million dollars Billy 100 million
dollars and we break it down through
case study method ok God and and and
you're doing this with collegiate
athlete on it with with with students is
it's not just collegiate athletes I've
done it I've done it with school this
past year just the athletes but mainly
that's how I want to be able to educate
to build my credibility within that
industry I already have some clients
that I'm working with but I'm not just
targeting athletes I'm targeting an
individual that that needs help in that
area you know I'm more I'm more about
the relationship of how what can I do
for you how can I be of service to you
because I'm not going to get everybody
are you teaming up with somebody
well yeah just me okay so you're sitting
at a desk trading all day I got it
that's weekly show you bring it in
somebody writes it a split maybe we
control the money on their management
yeah I fully so there's a team that's a
team I had two other partners that I
work with so let me let me clarify that
so just not me you know see let me be a
fighters of the Bahji today no it's very
thoughtful and thought-out I've teamed
up with my my personal financial advisor
for well over 20 years mr. Greg Eastman
they started no better way of doing it
if you know somebody if you trust them
there's a party yes and that's a great
partner for me so it gives me the
flexibility to do when I'm the right
projects on stage or in film and I can
carry my business wherever every with me
where I go my laptops so far savetti I
mean I means a it's and hey we can
create synergies we can do it because
the other guys you know that are doing
series similar coming in I feel good I
don't Antoine Walker and I sat down and
he was doing a partnership with Morgan
Stanley Dean would have to go talk to
the athletes to help him out because you
know the whole hundred ten million
dollars that he lost and he's talking
about it only so he has
different approach but he's not seven
going out there nothing is I just didn't
want to be a face of anything you get a
lot of these companies out here that
offer you say hey you don't have to do
all you know don't don't do all the work
you don't have to do much you know all
we want you to do is just go say this is
a great opportunity talk to this guy
and we'll give you a check or $500 or
$1,000 whatever that is for referral fee
why I get that when I can get a piece of
the pie good for you and compound over
time
no doubt about it I mean all I have to
do is sit my ass down and give them a
study for an exam a six and a half for
six and a half hour exam which is a
beast it's a bear took it twice so I
passed the burning sands of that so now
I want to get rewarded for their
lifetime just versus it's put my being
an endorsed or something I that's cool
for some but but seek the real ownership
and if I really want to do this then I'm
gonna do it and I've done just that both
in its athlete as an actor and now as a
wealth manager that you're your
Renaissance man Eddie I mean the initial
man you label the day I got to say Eddie
George Renaissance I mean are you
kidding me all the different things
you're talking about yeah that's a wide
range and in a you know Taj SWV you know
I was playing or music or something
week I give you in the legs but then
there's a one it wasn't one of them in
what was that one movie she was in the
ocean boy anything no boys and a hood
was above the rim above the rim yeah
above the rim which was stuff when he
came out it was a she wasn't above the
room as well and music was and above the
room with was it why coat would tank was
the one song she did with wu-tang was a
yes I think it's anything yeah so so
what's next for you man what are some
projects you're working on right now
right now
I'm obviously working on the wealth
manager side still prospecting clients
building relationships I have my jersey
retirement to retire my Jersey September
the 15th opening game home over against
Indianapolis Colts myself or Steve
McNair and that week we have a bunch of
events one events going to be on the
12th with myself and for a former enemy
of mine mr. Ray Lewis called cocktails
conversations and cigars where you know
ray and I have a very unique
relationship we go way back to 1996 we
both came out of college our friendship
started there became frenemies while we
play because we had such awesome but
painful wars he's clearly in my mind you
know one of the top five players to ever
play football ever because of ever ever
you're not even saying position no no no
he transcends that because he was a
quarterback on the field and I've seen
him do things on the field you're like
oh my god one film you know this team I
said wait a little bit I got to talk
about it his team's his team's early in
his career was so bad they were a
laughing joke but you will always see 52
around the football regardless
there was this one play with his running
back ran like 60 yards downfield
they're already losing like by three
touchdowns Baltimore he runs his ass
down on the sideline and catches on one
an angle and this guy's got speech I
can't remember the running backs name so
there's no quit in him there was none of
that so you're dealing with the alpha
alpha male in that and we've developed a
strong relationship so I want to talk
about our war stories playing football
but we're gonna talk about what we're
doing now Ray has a lot of different
interest he has a huge heart
he's a giving man has on seized up has
the entrepreneurial spirit and we're
going to talk about some of the things
that we're gonna collaborate on some
things that we're doing individually and
really try to enlighten entertain and
educate the audience and hopefully we
can make this into something that you
can see on television or do around the
country for different speaking
engagements different corporations you
know terms of leadership there's some
great things that we can bring to the
table in terms of Leadership Forum for
for business Minnesota you guys right
thinking about taking it that right
absolutely I fully see that that is of
course why not and this is just one
every want to do and sell it in a
celebratory environment of my my Jersey
getting retired that's that's incredible
money I'm excited for you excited win
when we get the news and ESPN or Stephen
a or somebody announces that I'm gonna
say we talked about this man when you
know we said you belong in the in the in
the Hall of Fame appreciated so what
we're gonna do is we're gonna put all
the information on whatever you got
working on will put it below even a
wealth management company Edward George
will put the link over George that's my
real name
yes yes will put that below if you got
any money management you want to reach
out to he and his team will put the link
below social media links will put below
as well and also I'm assuming there's a
website for this Arrington Vineyard yeah
but do that Eventbrite I can have my
assistants yeah well whatever for people
to get a hold of input today Eddie I got
a it felt like five minutes I I'm
getting signals cuz I never got to get
to a flight as well I appreciate you
flying out here to Dallas a man let's do
- then I'm definitely man Russell coming
up absolutely